c'est le hashtag jeudi photo postée
plein va bien sûr sur les réseaux
sociaux
et aujourd'hui donc y en a tout le monde
a amené une photo moi par exemple on a
découvert qu'il y avait l'équipe dans
l'équipe le sosie de michel drucker
regardez quand il était jeune regardez
c'est qui ça mokhtari sourire ah oui
vraiment c'est pas la même évolution
physique alors ils ont ils sont pas du
tout à la boîte à rire l'émotion
benjamin castaldi c'est quoi votre photo
alors c'est une photo de moi à la
campagne parce que comme je l'expliquais
est une verve et j'étais très proche de
la nature des animaux et qui est un
petit peu en petits paysans d'accord
elle est basée à ces notions regardez
c'est mignon et blanc c'est vous c'est
ouais en fait j'étais beau petit après
j'ai eu un gros moment j'étais moche et
je redeviens pas mal jusqu'à l'avant fin
et votre photo à vous eh ben c'est une
photo je me prend pour une star et je
dois avoir 10 11 ans cette fois ça c'est
drôle ça c'est belaiba web et il y avait
un truc s'appelait sisters sa raquette
mais c'est aux états unis at il souhaité
comment tu te la pètes avec calage la
bnm dont 110 111 ans à huit att deux
sortes et qu'un cap ou pas non mr osant
s'attaquer à crever peut-être avoir un
petit amoureux non non j'avais un
amoureux mais il se passait rien j'ai
franchement way allez vous oui bah c'est
super nous arrivions c'est ma photo avec
moi je
[Rires]
[Musique]
on n'a pas reçu le même mail de la
production c'est quoi ces suidés
l'émission ici à trois quatre ans j'ai
vu comme gage de passer tout le week-end
en lapin cgt partie jeu des parties
jusqu'à saint-etienne habillée comme ça
est ce que si je m'étais endormi contre
la vitre je bavais et dont j'ai reçu
plein de photos après sur twitter de moi
en train de baver le laval refaire ça la
thalasso week-end à 800 par mois toutes
les photos sont honteuses donc mépris
une à l'école en ce2 où je suis avec mes
plus beaux habits
c'est la plus folle bah oui normalement
cette mocheté cammas normalement tu les
vois et après tu les vois dans faites
entrer l'accusé
on n'a pas la photo de siprnet bébé en
stock ce qu'il avait lu le bénir garda
oui abb a ouai c'est le seuil des data
room deux ans déconner quoi c'est sa
vraie fausse mais qu'elle va garder ces
messieurs prévôtale weiler vénère 13 à
10 tf1 se fait entre l'accusé pas
horrible faire pipi punk abricoté il
vous ferai un petit côté hugues aufray
c'est loin d'être fait ma première photo
d'identité est la seule au contraire où
j'étais pas y de ce que j'étais
tellement moche qu'on me faisait baisser
la tête publiquement qu'on ne voit pas
le moins possible et donc là c'est la
seule potable où j'étais moi j'aime les
émigrés de vue quand j'étais donc c'est
s'asseoir et espère séduire et là
c'était qu'elle a déjà dit qu'ils
aideraient venir universal c'est fou ça
oui ma soeur et du procès c'est l'avion
parce que la grève était un facteur mais
bouffé mets préparés comme ça alors mon
coeur je n'ai deux mois donc une demande
de temps déjà pas mon coeur sinon j'aime
ou l'artichaut parce que j'aime bien on
effeuille quelques euros sans l'accord
de ses jolies alors je n'ai de une deux
mois passe quelque chose qu'elle
représente bien ce que je suis c'est à
dire à la fois le bien-être l'entretien
de soi et la culture dont je peux vous
la montrer
combien booking d'une bois bois de
province gp où cette belle et bien
masquer alors oui c'est intéressant de
préciser pourquoi ce petit match alors
c'est ça masque concombre et brocolis
non organise ses comptes encombre ben
non mais toi tu avais pas une faute
alors là oui ceci alors c'était en 1910
c'est à dire qu'à l'epoque là ma famille
on faisait pas de photos franchement
donc les photos et dans notre famille ne
faisait pas de photos ces trois siècles
et où pourquoi un doute tous trop moche
et en fait on a que des on n'a que des
photos et événementiel et la officiel
non mais c'est vrai quoi c'est la
première fois que vous avez ouvert votre
point soleil mais elle date j'avais 11
ans et c'était ma première communion
ah oui et pas alors je revois cette
neige terry parce qu'en fait à
l'internet on voyait plus ton zen avant
vienne et on dirait une boussole dirait
qu'ils pointent vers le bas mais sûr les
signaux en ville et les noms de la
mission non non non hélas la mèche c'est
qu'il y avait à l'été les mails et
sébastien et il avait une mèche et je
voulais faire pareil cela accord
maintenant diable embrasse est passé
chez mon choix j'ai un nom compliqué